[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the popular peter king
nbcsports.com the columnist football
morning in america released every monday
morning
peter let me start with the pressing
question are you an insider or an
outsider i think i'm
probably a quasi
insider i think 15 years ago
i would say i was
uh i was a lot more of an
insider i'm a little bit more of a
columnist slash observer
today because i don't do what
adam schefter ian rappaport and jay
glazer do
it very rarely will i break something
um and that just comes from the fact
that
you know i've lost uh
much of my interest in chasing things at
one o'clock in the morning
now if there's a great story
uh involved in it or you know something
that i can do that other people in our
business
maybe don't do as well those are the
kind of things i like to do today
but as far as breaking stories that's
not really me now
yeah i i'll dip my toe into being an
insider occasionally but it's right
it's a thankless job pete you know it
really is yeah yeah
and it's never-ending it's never-ending
like when does adam schefter take a real
vacation
i mean he's got to take it and look i i
love adam i really do
but there's a price to pay for being
the best you know and adam pays that
price
he's and again nobody's playing a violin
for him
he's well compensated he does a great
job but it's
and again adam is better
four eight times better than i ever was
at doing this job so i
i applaud him but man it's it's a
it's a it's a hard job well he broke the
andrew luck story while he was at a
wedding reception peter
so yeah i mean look anything to get out
of a wedding but still
you know your initial reaction to the
colts eagles trade is what
that i thought it was probably a
necessity
for the eagles unfortunately
um and i probably have a more unpopular
view on it than most
i mean i still haven't heard carson
wentz say
hey i played lousy last year
i mean could we at least hear that
i mean it seems like there's a lot of
people at fault
you know in that in him failing there
last year
uh but he should not escape
without some of the blame and i i just
haven't heard that
you know and dan the comparison i made
in the column today
you know he obviously took it badly
when uh 10 months ago the eagles
selected jalen hurts in the second round
of the draft
and you know i in my opinion
you know you've been hurt in a
significant way
twice in your career and the eagles
don't want to play nate sudfeld
when you're when you're hurt or josh
mccown they want a real legitimate
backup
that they could win games with and so
they draft
jalen hurts it was a smart move at least
in my opinion
nobody agrees with me but i think it was
a smart move
and he just chafed against it he thought
he was
being submarine and and that kind of
bugs me
in 2014 the patriots took jimmy
garoppolo in the second round
and tom brady responded this way
i'll show you thinking you're drafting
my replacement
i got plenty of good football left well
in the first three years he won two
super bowls first three years of the
garoppolo
uh era and then in the fourth year in
the middle of the year they traded
garoppolo and brady was on his way to an
mvp
season that's how you respond you
respond like aaron rodgers does
when they draft jordan love you just say
okay
you drafted jordan love that's fine i'll
show you
and he did are the eagles set at
quarterback
i don't think so they don't think so
they could pick one at six they could
give jalen hurts one year to try to win
the job
and start to buttress a roster that is
i mean as crazy as this sounds the
philadelphia eagles might have the
fourth best
best roster right now today in the nfc
east and uh you know they've gone in the
span
of basically uh four months
from thinking that doug peterson and
carson wentz were going to be the
leaders of their
organization for the next five years
so now neither of them are there i think
the organization is shell-shocked
quite frankly dan i you know i just
think they
are thinking what the heck just
happened you know three years ago we
were having a parade in
uh you know down broad street and now
we are in tatters it's it's just one of
the weirdest stories in sports really
the cold side of this uh with frank
reich being reunited with carson wentz
the upside the offensive line i mean
that's that's a that's a
good team good gm um
is it an upgrade over philip rivers
i mean we'll find out i think phillip
rivers was a good quarterback
uh and you know he
he had he had the colts in a playoff
game late
and came close to beating buffalo
so he's he he did his job
but you know the colts what they knew
is they had to stop scotch taping their
quarterbacks
thing together dan you know including
this year in the last three years
they've spent 99.2 million
dollars on the quarterback position and
they're not positive they've solved it
i mean they they have got to get this
right
and so i think look if you look at the
way carson wentz played
from 17 to 19 that
was really good it was top
seven top eight top nine quarterback in
the league
you can win a super bowl with that now
can they get him back to that
there's every reason to think they
should he trusts reich
but you know part of this is dan he's
gonna have to take some hard coaching
and he carson wentz is gonna have to
take responsibility
instead of just saying well i don't have
this or i don't have that
and again don't get me wrong i've never
heard him say that
he hasn't said that but all of his
actions
basically point to
i was i was job here you know so
he's not going to have any excuses in
indianapolis is peter king
must read every uh monday morning
football morning in america
nbcsports.com the team that should
break the bank for deshaun watson is who
well i think the team that should do it
is the jets
but i don't think they will um i think
that joe douglas is a build through the
draft guy
and they have so many high picks
you know they got four ones in the next
two years i don't think they want to
denude
their draft in the next two or three
years
uh for anybody and so
i i think the team that really makes the
most sense
as we sit here this morning is carolina
because carolina can give a top 10 pick
back this year
i think their owner david tepper will
stop
at nothing to get a franchise
quarterback and then he will look at
his new gm scott federer and his coach
matt rule and say
you guys figure out all the other pieces
you know
we're gonna go get a franchise
quarterback even if it costs
a couple of great pieces like either
christian mccaffrey or brian burns
uh and and three or four very high picks
i think the panthers are going to be
aggressive that would be my prediction
but if you're desean watson do you want
to go into a situation like
carolina that's going to be depleted
with
losing a first-round draft pick
christian mccaffrey
who won't be depleted that's the
question
if you're if let's say the only the only
team that
might not be really significantly
depleted
is san francisco because they have
really good
quality depth in their young players and
prospects
but almost anywhere that he goes
it's gonna cost you think washington can
get away
with trading for deshaun watson
without uh including one or more of
their
great very young defensive players like
chase young
you know so anywhere he goes
is going to be without three or four
very high picks
and one or two good players
i'm still trying to figure out what bill
belichick is doing
because he's always ahead of everybody
it feels like but it feels like he's
behind everybody with the quarterbacking
situation
it's quiet now they normally don't let
anything out pete but
if you're looking at a short-term or
long-term game plan what's your best
guess to what the patriots are up to
my best guess is they're going to draft
somebody uh
i just you know do you want to cast your
lot
with pick a guy mitchell trubisky
i mean do you want to cast your lot with
jimmy garoppolo
and and i again i'm not throwing
garoppolo on the trashy
i am saying you know in the last three
years he's missed 23 of 48 regular
season games with injury
tom brady missed 15 regular season games
due to injury
in 20 years so i i don't know that
even if you traded for garoppolo or
somehow got garoppolo
that that's a magic wand waved over the
quarterback position
i you know look it's going to be
interesting to see if i were the
patriots
i might uh because no veteran out there
it really sort of turns you on uh you
know who's gonna be available
uh and so i might rather just take a mac
jones or if tray lance falls that far
you know i i might just rather draft
somebody but there's no question
but dan that's not the only position
they they're in trouble
with their skill position uh roster is
absolutely horrendous so they've got to
do something
about that too no matter what
quarterback they bring in what's drew
brees waiting for
i have no idea this is it's weird to me
it just is
i know he went on vacation with his
family for a while
um but it's been whatever 30-something
days
uh since jay glazer went on fox and said
you know
brees is retiring everybody knows that
he's got a tv
job waiting uh i i truly don't know dan
i asked some people that question
this weekend and it was met with i don't
know
j.j watt what do you think the biggest
to make his decision what do you think
it'll hinge on
uh the ability to win this year i don't
think money is going to be a very big
factor
um i do think that
uh if if it were up to him if he could
pick a team
it would probably be green bay i think
it'd be a dream of his to run out of the
tunnel at lambeau field
in green and gold um but
at the end of the day i also think he's
gonna look at
where he would be i think the browns are
an interesting
team because they could rightfully say
to him
you're going to play opposite miles
garrett you're not going to get nearly
the attention
you've got in the last few years in
houston
but i also think there would be an
attraction
if a team like kansas city stepped up
too i think it's really
really important for him to be able to
enter training camp this year thinking
if everything goes right we're we're
going to win a ring
when uh do the steelers have to make a
decision on ben roethlisberger
it's a weird one i think there's more at
play than just finances
i you know i don't you just get the
feeling from listening to kevin colbert
last week that that i mean in my opinion
it's not only about finances you got to
look at the way the last month of this
season went and
man that is a bad omen for the future
um ben roethlisberger looked old and
slow
and i personally i think that
this should be a season that if he wants
to play this year
he really needs to rededicate himself
physically
to you know being
a better and more fit roethlisberger
yeah it feels like they've already moved
on from him but you want to be
respectful to him
and and sort of let him come to the
realization or
let him have his day where he gets to
announce it but you know when somebody
says well ben's our quarterback for the
time being or at the moment
that doesn't have a ringing endorsement
there that ben will be back with
pittsburgh
agreed and dan you know what i think if
you're the pittsburgh steelers
you know there are many things that they
do but
they don't often stay one or two years
too long
with someone i think maybe in the very
early 90s they might have learned their
lesson with chuck noll
that was a team that stayed a year or
two too long and no wonder
the guy won four super bowls for him he
should get to call his shot
but i don't know how the steelers with
the losses they're going to have
probably losing bud dupree probably
losing juju smith schuster
i i i you know i don't know and i don't
know what they're going to be able to
add
free agency they were sort of you hate
to say they were a tenuous 11-0
but didn't it have that feeling that
they were a tenuous 11-0 yeah
and uh i'm not saying they got what they
deserve down the stretch
that's a little cruel but i mean
you know they they looked really bad all
except for that comeback against the
colts
and i think they've got to rethink the
immediate and long-term future of their
organization
pete thank you as always we appreciate
your time
okay dan all the best to you that's
peter king he's not an insider or an
outsider
maybe he's like me he's a tweener